- De la fumée s'élève
dans le ciel de la capitale.
Des missiles se sont abattus
ici, tout près de Kiev.
La Russie affirme avoir détruit
la plu9ó+Iéserve
de carburant de l'armée
ukrainienne.
"Dans la première phase
de notre opération militaire,
dit ce général rusénéral rusénés
atteint nos objectifs.
Les capacités de combat
des forces ukrainiennes
ont été réduites.
Nous souhaitons maintenant
réaliser notre objectif
principal : la libération
du Donbass."
Cette région de l'est
de l'Ukraine est convoitée
par Moscou depuis des années.
Devant un parterrede journaliss
du Kremlin prétendent qu'ils
n'ont jamais voulu s'emparer de
Kiev ou d'autres grandes villes.
Pourtant, Kharkiv a été
la cible de bombardements
encore aujourd'hui, et Marioupol
est en grande partie détruite.
Parmi les centaines
de personnes qui s'étaient
réfugiées dans le théâtre
bombardé la semaine dernière,
au moins 300 sont mortes,
a annoncé la mairie.
L'entrée de cet abri est
toujours bloquée par des déb
Selon des informations reçues
par les Nations unies, il y a
bel et bien des fosses communes
dans la Ville assiégée
de Marioupol.
L'une d'entre elles
contiendrait environ 200 corps.
Les résidents commencent aussi à
manquer d'eau et de nourriture.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Nous allons, en lien avec
la Turquie et avec la Grèce,
lancer une opération humanitaire
pour évacuer toute
et ceux qui souhaitent quitter
Marioupol.
"Cela fait 30 jours, un mois",
dit le président Zelensky.
Il dit aux Russes qu'il est
nécessaire de chercher la paix,
qu'ils ne savent pas ce qui
nd.nd.nd.nd.nd.nd.
L'Ukraine se targue d'ailleurs
d'avoir coulé un navire
de transport de troupes russes
ancré dans le port de Berdiansk,
en mer d'Azov. Malgré une
domination sur papier,
Moscou se heurte toujours
à une résistance aussi
déterminée qu'inattendue.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Mon